- I met Gary at some
conferences, I saw you speaking
and I was just, I thought
this man was a genius.
And, not just the content that
was coming out of his mouth,
which was so helpful to
a lot of these stalwarts
that were in this room that
just were very clueless
and were five years, ten years behind
when it came to what their
companies needed to do
in terms of social media.
But also his energy, and
he has this thing where,
no matter what he says, you listen.
Not only do you listen,
you feel like oh my god,
now I have to do it.
I have to execute on what he's saying.
So, come on up.
And this is his second year doing this.
(audience applauding)
- I got it.
- We have a desk, wow, it's very newsy.
- Hello class, how are you?
I'm doin' a lot of things,
but it's really interesting.
I'm doin' a lot a lot of things that,
there's 50 other things I
could tell you I'm up to,
but it's really
interesting, and it's really
what we're talking about
here in it's most basic form.
I'm actually only doing one thing.
I'm day trading attention.
I'm doing one very simple thing.
I think the world is
in change, and I think
that there's overpriced
and under-priced attention.
We're spending a lot of time here,
I remember from last
year, I'd been listening,
even though I was on my phone
for the first 30 minutes,
here I think there's a lot of,
a lot of conversation
here around the content.
You know, meaning, how do
I want to present myself?
A lot of things you've been debating
and asking questions about?
I think that it's a
really interesting thing
to make something happen, to
make everything that you want
to happen, it takes
content and distribution.
And there's very few people
that are doing a good job
and really understanding
both of them at the same time
and more importantly, unlike
the world we grew up in,
where distribution was so
stagnant and understood,
the content didn't factor
distribution into it.
For example, making a 22 minute sitcom
doesn't take into account
television distribution
'cause it didn't have to.
Whereas making a video for
Instagram or Facebook or YouTube
has to understand how distribution works
to have a chance to be successful.
So artists are struggling with math,
and mathematicians are
struggling with art.
- So you said there's,
who's doing it good?
- I'm not sure, and that's the truth,
because I don't really
spend any time on auditing
who's doing it well or doing
it good or doing it smart.
I spend 100% of my time on
the end consumer's attention.
- So I wanna talk about
attention when it comes to you.
You have built this business
that continues to grow.
I mean, last year, it was
double the size or something.
But you also have a personal brand.
A huge personal brand.
A personal brand that a
lot of people know you
as this kind of celebrity CEO
and don't even really
understand your businesses
but understand you.
- That's right.
- And the value that you're bringing
to their lives.
- That's right.
- So tell me about the
decision to make yourself
a personal brand and why.
- YouTube was two months old.
I saw it, I'm like oh shit,
this is gonna be the next big thing,
and I started a wine
show in February 2006.
I sat at a desk like this and
drank four bottles of wine
for 20 minutes and it exploded.
Google, Yahoo, because Yahoo
video was big at the time,
Yahoo and Google, Google
had bought YouTube
when they flew me out.
But very early on, I had
20 minute shows on YouTube.
Like if you go back to YouTube
and search videos that were made in 2006,
nobody was making 20
minute videos like I was.
I was just long winded and talked a lot
and so they dragged out,
but I built a personal brand
very early on in the scheme of things
because of the YouTube show,
and then Twitter came out
and that's when I started getting smart
and started investing in these things.
I'm like oh, that's gonna
be the next big thing.
So I got on Twitter early, I
was one of the first 25 people
in the world to have a
million followers on Twitter,
which is really wild
because everybody else
was from Tech TV and,
you know, Digg Nation,
and it was very techy,
Twitter the first two years.
I was a wine retailer in New Jersey.
- What did you think--
- So I built a brand early.
- What did you think using
your face, your name,
your likeness, meant to the business?
Was it just about being
famous or was it about--
- No. I thought I was gonna do QVC
the first day I did Wine Library TV.
By the time my stock guy
who set up the camera
was set up and we were
ready to film, I got scared.
A friend, I recalled this very recently,
I did something very early on in my career
where it was extremely noble for,
pretty radical reasons
that I didn't even need to
or should have even maybe, right?
And the kid asked me why did I do that?
And my answer was, because I'm scared
that Dateline's gonna roll up
on me and ask me the question.
Intuitively, at it's earliest point,
I understood the internet was gonna expose
all the shadows of our society.
Like, at a very young
age, I figured it out.
I didn't realize it, but
all my actions spoke to it.
So when Wine Library TV's
first episode started,
even though I wanted to sell wine,
I was like shit, what if I'm at a party,
and somebody gives me a glass of wine
and says, if Ryan's like hey,
what do you think of this wine?
And I'm like, oh it's terrible,
you're like, well you're a piece of shit,
you said it was phenomenal on episode 136.
And I was so scared of that,
that basically from the beginning,
I went ultra transparent,
but I thought I was,
I was doing it for business.
I was 32 years old, I was an
entrepreneur business man,
there was no fame, there was no,
I was already you know, I was a grown up.
Like I wasn't thinking, it
wasn't what I dreamed to do,
it's nothing that I, I
never thought that I would
walk the rec FO like I just did right now
and take nine selfies.
That was never a part of the equation,
it was for business, I was a business man.
- Do you think having a personal brand
is making you more money?
- A hundred percent, but
I don't think you need
a personal brand to build your business.
I think you need self-awareness
to build your business.
And so, even listening
to some of the questions,
like David D's question here,
like when I was listening
to some of the questions,
and I brought this up last year in this,
and I'm gonna say this again,
I understand the class you're in,
but I'm an unbelievable buyer
of betting on your strengths
and punting your weaknesses.
And the thought of
operators and entrepreneurs
forcing themselves to
create personal brands
is laughable, because
nine out of ten of 'em
that I know have no shot.
Or are gonna waste way too much energy,
or it's super uncomfortable.
Now that doesn't mean
if you're an introvert,
you know, it was funny,
when you talk about
somebody just standing there,
I've always thought about authenticity.
Like if you are actually
monotone, if like,
for example, I think
entertainment and, you know,
I have shtick, fine.
That works for me.
But some of the stuff that I most enjoy
is just depth of knowledge.
The people that have followed
me around personal brands,
a lot of them are not
charismatic or pretty
or that interesting, there's
just such a deep expert
in their field that their podcast,
for example, is dominating.
And even their video of just like them
straight at the camera,
not dressed the part,
not all that charismatic,
a little bit awkward,
but their information--
- But to me,
that's still a personal brand.
- Well that's where I'm going,
I totally agree.
- At the beginning
of this course, I say that
it's not about being big
and it's not about being like you,
but you can be shy, you can be awkward,
you can be, and you can lean into that.
- A hundred percent.
- That can be your
personal brand.
- And then just having context
of like, what I'm assuming
the ambition of this room is.
It's about self awareness.
And back to my self awareness, you know,
as it started happening I'm like, oh yeah,
I was a good class clown and oh yeah,
I do wanna talk at the dinner table
and control the conversation.
So like, it became obvious to me,
wait a minute, there's something here.
And then when I made the
transition of talking
about business, not about wine,
it really went to a
totally different place
because, you know, this is what's great
about documenting everything,
I was saying things
that nobody agreed with and
then ended up being true.
You know, like ...
- Like what?
- Like Instagram is gonna
get bought by Facebook,
and that became true, and then
I'm on CNN for predicting it
and then they're making fun of me
because it was a billion
dollars and I said he stole it.
And if you go read the comments
on YouTube of the clip,
the first two years
everybody makes fun of me:
asshole, pushing propaganda,
how can you pay a billion
dollars for a company
that's only 500 days old.
And then the last two
years, it's like genius,
he fucking knew, you know.
So what's amazing is
being historically correct
is the most valuable thing to do.
I think one of the great reasons
to build a personal brand
is to document, you know, imagine
watching the documentation
of all the things we put on a pedestal.
Like imagine if Steve Jobs
had a vlog back in the day.
Like, the learning, for me the reason--
- What percentage of your
day that you document?
'Cause I know you
document a heck of a lot.
- Iris is filming right now.
- Oh god, Iris.
- Some.
- What's tough for me is I'm
operating an actual business,
so there's a lot of firing and negotiating
and a lot of stuff we don't film.
I do film a lot of it,
just for my grandkids to watch one day--
- Film somebody being fired?
- I haven't, I haven't.
I haven't done that
because I just feel bad,
yeah I don't think that's,
but I'll film things that, or I'll ask,
or I'll film from afar.
You know, I also am projecting technology.
One of the biggest
reasons I document my life
is that I think my kids
are gonna sell the IP
of people being able to be in meetings
with me in the future
and be our environment.
So there's a lot of
chess that I'm playing.
I do a lot of things--
- I have a question.
I'm gonna ask you about the class
and some of them, how
many of you are on social?
How many are on?
And how many's on nothing?
A few, I'm gonna be you in 15 years.
Definitely, it is a goal of mine.
So they're in so many different sectors,
in consulting to retail to entertainment,
I mean so many different sectors.
Talk about what each platform means
which should help them say, okay,
I need to spend more time here.
So let's start with Facebook.
- Okay, before you we
that, just to frame it up,
first of all we have to decide, you know,
what you're doing, meaning,
you know I always question
would I have even been
on social media if I didn't
use it for business purposes.
Like, I don't consume content.
You were talkin' about, you
know, some of the streaming TV,
like I consume very little outside
of the Knicks and the Jets,
my consumption of actual
content, because I'm reading,
I'm consuming people's
behavior on the internet.
That's what I'm doing and consuming.
So I think as individuals,
that and Adam, that's great,
like I don't think that's
weird, that's fine.
I think a business not being
on it is ludicrous, right?
So, are you asking me on
a personal brand level?
- Personal brand.
- Okay, on a personal brand
level, Facebook is the single
most important platform
still, because of scale.
Just true general scale, unless
what you wanna talk about
and what you're about
only skews 21 and under,
you have to be on Facebook.
To me that's oxygen.
- And what should they
be talking about on Facebook?
And then let's talk about the difference
between a personal Facebook page
and a business Facebook page,
with them as the head of their business.
Should it be one, or
should it be separate?
- What Tyra's talking
about is there's two ways
to play on Facebook, you
can build a business page,
a personal page, if you have
any commercial ambitions
it should be a business page.
They work different on the algorithm,
you'll have different tools,
so the answer is, for business purposes,
we're here, it's a business page.
You should be talking
about whatever the hell
you wanna be talking about.
- Should you share family
stuff or personal stuff
on the business page or keep it business?
- No, I'm a very big believer
that people overthink this.
I think you can go anywhere with it.
I think you know, look at
data and see what happens.
Some people resonate on a
personal level, others don't.
Again, I think this comes
down to self-awareness.
I also think the type of content
you post is self-awareness.
There's people in here that
can write their ass off
but like freeze when
there's a camera, you know?
I can't put two sentences together,
but I can do my thing
when there's a camera.
There's audio, there's
pictures, there's captioning it.
You're clever, you're smart.
So there's a lot of variables.
I think, you know, one
thing that I wanna make sure
all of you understand is
that the written word,
video, and audio have been the way
we've always consumed stuff
and it's the way we will
always consume stuff.
And so I think, one of the things is,
right now the medium is so visual
that I think a lot of people here
are pressured into thinking
it's about the camera world,
and I think there's an incredible upside
in written word and audio.
I think everybody at
this point understands
it's a lot bigger than we thought
three or four years ago.
- I was just gonna talk about
it in a second, because
you talked about it
last year and it's blown up.
Instagram?
- You know, so Instagram's
the next establishment,
it is the establishment,
it is the most contemporary
and important platform, in my opinion.
It's already gotten to the
50- and 60-year-old set,
so it's pretty much now at scale, right?
There's an awful lot of attention on it.
I think that, for most people,
it's a requirement as well for me.
DMing on Instagram is
stunningly effective,
even to the most powerful people.
So that's a little fun fact.
I think there's access that's
playing out on Instagram.
Yeah, I mean, it's an
incredibly important product.
- And how important is it that the photo
be aesthetically pleasing
in some type of way?
- I have empathy if you come
from the industry you come from,
if somebody says that they're
building a high fashion brand,
I still think that Cartier's best move
is to show a little humility
and a little not fanciness.
So, I think anything that
acts human always wins,
so for me, I'm less precious about that,
but for you and Cartier,
if that's 90% of it,
I understand that, but I
don't think it means anything.
When you talk about my
Instagram looks like a mess,
I don't think a lot of people,
I think we overthink the
way it looks as a net.
I go on Tyra's account,
and we under-think about
what it looks like in screen,
which is how we actually consume it.
So I've gotten a different point of view
than the market on that.
- Snapchat, which I don't understand
how to use that damn thing.
I still don't, I don't
know what I'm doing.
I was doing, trying to
record videos the other day
for something else, but
using their filters,
and I was like I have no idea
if the whole world is looking at that.
- Snap is still extremely big, you know,
13 to 28, but the story
feature on Instagram
took a lot of momentum out of the system.
- As soon as Instagram started stories,
I was not using Snapchat anymore.
- Yep. You know, for me,
I think trading attention,
I think Snapchat is actually
one of the most interesting
places to be on right now,
because everybody bounced.
Yet, there's still an
ungodly amount of attention
if you care about 11 to 30.
If you're doing B2B hardware,
Snap is not gonna matter, but Facebook is.
And I think people don't understand
that Facebook would for
a company like that.
But again, if you're starting
a lifestyle fashion brand,
and maybe your audience
is millennials 25 to 45,
if you're a really thoughtful marketer,
you'll realize that winning 13 to 22
will drive your business.
So, I think Snap matters if you
care about winning under 25,
but I'm not convinced that
they make it out of this,
they're gonna have to
innovate their product,
they're gonna have to come
up with something now.
Snap has wisely invested in AR.
You know, they own Bitmoji.
There's things they're doing.
And I think Evan's a very
uniquely interesting guy,
I know him a little bit.
I know Snap extremely well, but I think,
to me that is a nice to
have versus a requirement,
other than, again,
if you're starting a hoodie
company it's requirement.
- Twitter.
- Twitter's the water
cooler of our society,
you know, which has an
important place to be.
I think Twitter's more
about listening and reacting
than pushing out content,
which is why so many people
struggle with Twitter.
So for example, even you
said, my Twitter's a mess,
the engagement's low, that makes sense,
it's a fire hose, too much content.
However, if you personally
use Twitter different
than you used everything else,
instead of posting on it,
it's when you engage with people
or jumped into conversations
or culture hackin' it, you would crush.
- That's what my guys doing now.
- If you would jump into like,
when Ninja and Drake are on Twitch,
if you jump in and is like
boys, leave a seat for me,
it would've been huge for you.
Got it?
So it's a counter punching
platform around copy.
And this is super important,
I think you're getting a sense
from me, like I'm telling you right now,
the world is grossly underestimating
the strategy and nuances
of these platforms.
I think you can tell,
this is not like ha ha ha,
this is very deep, psychographic
mathematical creative strategy.
Twitter I think is remarkably interesting.
For example, Wendy's is
growing their business
flat out on the back of snarky
and clever Twitter engagement.
And guess what?
Twitter engagement
doesn't cost you $80,000
for video production, doesn't cost any,
see where I'm going?
So, there's a lot of people
here who are quite clever,
and that might be the platform,
and that is, actually,
it's tough to like, well
what am I gonna post?
What's amazing about Twitter
is, you don't have to do that.
You can just follow the
conversations, get involved.
Like there's a meme right now going on
based on do you hear, right?
There's such a place for that,
there's such a place,
you have to be creative,
it's creative writing.
Like, this is where I
think improv writers,
comedy writers, should live on Twitter
'cause they have that sensibility.
- What about Google Plus?
- It doesn't exist.
(laughs)
- You know, it kills me because
I have seven million
followers, I have seven people.
- You have seven fake
million fake followers.
They would be fake because
what they did at one point
was they used Gmail, and there
was something else, buzz,
I'm tryin' to remember.
They completely fabricated
the top of the funnel,
how much you actually had
predicated on how much
we use Google for other things,
so it made us all feel good--
- I still spend no time
there, even though--
- I don't think, I genuinely
live my life this way,
and haven't thought
about it for four years
let alone been there.
- And then, the obvious one, Linkedin.
- Linkedin's super interesting
because Linkedin was a
utility, for you know, jobs,
and has absolutely evolved
into a content platform.
Linkedin's an incredibly
thoughtful place for a lot of you.
It's a place to do white
papers and thoughtful,
it's an incredibly interesting b2b place,
but it's about producing content,
it's about blogging and making videos
and posting on Linkedin,
not spamming people
and messaging them to like
get a contract from them.
- And then, is there
anything on the horizon?
Like is there, this is the next.
You're smelling it and that people need to
get on there early because
the earlier you get on
you tend to have a bigger following.
- So, I think of social
media more as like content,
because that's really
what it involves into.
I'm completely obsessed with podcasting.
- So that was my question.
So last year, you kinda
went around the room
and said if you're not doin' a podcast,
I'm paraphrasing, you're an idiot.
I'm paraphrasing, but it
was something like that.
And me, hearing that, not as a student,
but hearing that, I felt like an idiot,
and next year I'm gonna
do a version of that.
- I love it.
- Because you said
that last year.
- I was super right about that,
and I'm happy about it
because it's really helped
a lot of my, you know,
all my content's free,
my audience watches it, I love
the idea of them benefiting.
And so many of my audience,
because of that rant
that I was going on two years ago.
I mean voices, get ready,
like no question most exciting
thing for me in technology is the voice,
and blockchain's an
unbelievable technology,
it's the internet itself.
There's so much to talk about.
AR's gonna be super rad,
machine learning and AI,
super interesting.
But for me, the reason I'm obsessed
with voice and the apps
that are gonna be built
on top of Alexa and
Google Home and Apple Pod
is that we're about to be affected
for real for real in about 36 months.
You are going, I would
say, looking around,
you would've never guessed,
I bet you all of you,
looking around, just kind
of gauging ages here,
it would've been hard for you to believe
how much texting compared
to how much phone calling
you would be doing.
If I sat here eight years ago and said,
I promise you, 96% of your
behavior is gonna be texting,
not calling, you would've had a tough time
making that leap.
You would've said maybe 50-50.
I'm sayin' it right now,
remember it one day,
I can't wait for you to email me,
you are gonna be blown away
by how much voice interaction
you're gonna do in seven years.
You're not gonna type,
you're not gonna type.
Which is like crazy, right.
- But are we gonna read?
So you think we're gonna hear it?
- Look look, guys, everything
goes in a circle, right?
Everything goes in a circle.
I didn't think I was
gonna type in my life,
sitting in high school.
I'm gonna be an entrepreneur,
I'm not gonna type.
I'm not fucking use, why would I type?
Then my whole life became type, right?
It's all type, it's all, now
we're all deep into type,
we're gonna go back to it
because what we care about is
lack of friction and speed,
and it's going to be faster
for you to do something
without voice device always on,
everywhere, always, than it
is to take out your phone
and text your mom.
You'll be like mom, I'm gonna be late,
and it's gonna be done.
We're talkin' about
like, so it's way way way
bigger than you think--
- That scares the hell
out of me.
- So my mom, she's living with me now
and she had an Alexa, and I was like
get that thing out my house right now
because I'm just so nervous
about being recorded,
everything that I say being recorded.
But it's a generational thing.
I care, my son's not gonna care.
- Of course, of course.
And eventually we're all gonna understand
that privacy doesn't
exist, which is gonna be
the best thing for the human race.
Just on the record.
Iris, you caught that?
It's just going to be.
- So, speaking of this, what are the ways
that you can get in
trouble with social media?
Is it an oversharing, is it a--
- I think you can get in trouble
when somebody else has leverage.
- What's that mean?
- It means if you work for somebody,
or if you are being financed
by somebody, they have say.
I don't think you can
lose with the audience.
I think that's been proven,
time and time again.
You basically say you're
sorry and you move on.
It's a remarkably human thing.
It's why we're still around.
Our compassion, ability
to forgive is enormous.
Think about what you'd have
to really do to massively,
I mean where, where are you going?
I mean you gotta, you're really
into the most extreme
territories, which is,
if you're doing those things,
if you're murdering somebody,
I promise you the tweet is
the last of your concerns,
so this place of like, I can
fuck this up, you really can't.
Where you can, so the audience.
The audience, the market,
you have no danger.
You have danger if somebody
has leverage on you.
You have danger if
Rick, the VC who's about
to write you a check, didn't like
that you said that and now doesn't.
And I think the reason I've
been ale to live so free
is I've never put myself in a place
where somebody has financial impact on me.
He's super fired up.
- Oh, you have a question?
- So I actually, I'm
sure you probably know
some of these guys.
Like I used to watch these
daily vlogs every day,
like Casey and this other guy
Jesse who was always with him,
and both of them eventually,
they stopped doing their vlogging
and their social media presence
was severely dialed back
because they were talking about having
this mixture of personal and professional,
it negatively impacted their businesses
and it negatively impacted
their personal relationships.
So I wanted to kind of get your view
on how do we prevent that
from happening or, you know,
the conflict that might be there.
- I don't think we stopped
that from happening, you know.
We're not gonna make rules of that.
Like that never works.
I mean, if you look at Casey's situation,
he stopped for two reasons.
One, he got 25 million dollars from CNN,
two he, you know when you do something
for a long time you get burnt out.
He's also super back, you know last month
he started a full studio for it.
He's also started a podcast with his wife
to talk about the issues of it.
So thinking of the watch behavior,
I think we overthink that
we can regulate stuff.
What I like about the
internet is it's exposing us,
not changing us.
Like, how do you stop, you stop.
Like I don't think it's up to us
or Google or Facebook.
Like I love all this Facebook talk,
like, people are mad for a platform
exposing who you actually are.
So, you know, my point of view is,
I don't think it's as much
of a collective conversation
as people think.
For example, people wanna
say that social media
has a lot to do with teenage
suicide and bullying,
what they don't wanna talk about
is that modern day parenting
is so over-coddling,
we do not put our kids in a position
to feel any detrimental actions
in the first seven years of their life,
which then forms a reality
that they're so entitled
and unable to deal with any adversity.
So, we are having very
basic conversations.
- Let's talk about that some more,
with the basic conversation,
that people are so scared
to do anything, to say anything,
because of the mob mentality.
And now there is no trial before fire.
So talk about that.
One tweet could really ruin your life.
- The data doesn't show that.
- I disagree, I keep seein' it constantly.
- Well let's talk about it.
You're saying that
people don't wanna talk,
people are talking more than ever.
- No I'm saying that,
people are scared to be free
with their tweeting or their social
because they're scared that
something's going to happen.
- Let's say Jess is like that.
Well that's who she would've been in life.
Again, technology is exposing who we are.
There's millions of people we're not.
There's people who are.
- But can you talk about,
that there is a possibility
of somebody tweeting something
that could ruin their life.
- I just don't agree with you.
I'd love to know who.
- I don't know the names but
it in the news constantly.
- Yeah but I think you see,
I think ruining your
life is very different
than having turbulence for two weeks.
You see it constantly
because there's a moment.
Let's talk about the combination,
let's talk about the most extreme case.
The woman who made a racist joke
about HIV in Africa and was on a plane
and fucking Google made
the search result of her
follow her plane path and when
she'd landed in South Africa,
everybody was there?
She's doing fine.
No, listen, I really wanna have
this convo because this
is a smart crew, right?
Let's have smart conversations.
Ruining life is just not
happening from a tweet.
I'm just gonna put it down.
Like if you can show me the
ones, like it's just not.
- Yeah, I can't back up what I'm saying.
- [Audience Member]
What about politicians?
Like an Anthony Wiener.
I mean that ruined his entire life.
- Yeah but the action is
what you have to look at.
Tweeting like fuck you or using the N word
or like things that we
would be super offensive
in reaction to is not ruining lives.
The actions of like, engaging
with an underage woman
in sexual behavior, like
you have to map back
to the action, not the tweet.
- [Audience Member] But he
could have never gotten caught
if he didn't take
pictures of his genitals.
- Of course, but be he could've too.
Right? Again, I think we're having
a really interesting, but he could've.
But he could've, and people have
and I think the more important question
is that, what happens next?
Because now the Anthony
Wiener who's eleven
will know that the world
is watching much more
and it may formulate his behavior
and never got into place because the world
that Anthony Wiener
grew up in and the world
that I grew up in was
mainstream media protected
all this bad behavior.
Matt Lauer and the Harvey
Weinstein and Anthony Wiener's
of the world were protected
by the alternative
to the internet, cold traditional media.
Protected.
And life's about alternatives.
So we demonize this new technology,
which is actually doing
incredible good for us as humans,
we're just in a certain chapter
where we're going through the middle stage
where we're reconciling.
- I disagree with you, but
I don't have the knowledge
that you have to be able to debate you.
- No no, actually I apologize.
Let us three have this
for five, two more minutes
because it's important.
You disagree, meaning?
- [Audience Member] I
disagree, meaning that,
so a lot of people do,
probably, what he did, a lot.
Especially in politics.
But he's the one that took that action
to then, which was then the
final catalyst of his downfall.
There's probably thousands
of other politicians
that are doing what he did.
- Doing what?
- I have a question.
- Go ahead, please.
- Which relates to this,
which is, if there are
people who ignore gender,
your race, your socioeconomic status,
or your position or power,
that indicates whether or not you rebound
or whether or not it has adverse effects
that you cannot bounce back from.
And I would like to just
get your thoughts on--
- The internet doesn't change, it exposes.
- But people's impressions
on how they view the action
are dependent upon how you view
the individual's identity--
- A hundred thousand percent.
But the internet, to me the
question is like, a tweet isn't,
let's go back to the original seed.
A tweet or the form of
communication isn't the culprit,
there's far deeper things
that we've taken this
conversation to, right?
Like Michael Vick going to jail
for having dogs fighting
and Ben Roethlisberger raping two women
is a very big difference.
One's a white male, one's a black male.
One goes to jail for fighting dogs,
one gets away with it, twice.
That's not Twitter.
- I think it still is Twitter, because
there's a mob mentality, and
it makes companies scared--
- Let's not be ideological,
let's then talk about alternatives.
Cool, fine, it's Twitter.
Then what about what the New York Times
or the Wall Street
Journal or CBS was then?
Like so we'd rather have eight,
three people be in charge
of who's persecuted or not?
- I'm not saying it's good or bad,
I'm just saying it's fact
that somebody says something
on a social network, on a platform,
and because companies,
advertisers, whatever it is,
are being led by the mob,
they tend to act quick
and swift and fast, and it
can really ruin somebody,
whether it's for two weeks--
- But again, the woman
on Fox saying something
and everybody reacts on the internet
because a kid retweets from Florida
could've also been the New
York Times featuring that.
You're talking about more scale,
but I don't think we're
talking about, you know,
it's a very interesting
conversation, obviously
we're getting, you know, into this,
which is super fun for me.
To me, it's just about alternatives,
and I don't think
somebody's life is ruined
by a tweet, but I think
the actions, if picked up
and hitting the consciousness of America.
- We're gonna do one more
and then we're gonna move on.
- So I'm interested to hear, do you think,
Anthony Wiener would have
survived had Twitter not been,
because I think--
- I think Anthony
Wiener's survived, anyway.
Like, his political career in the way
that we're contextualizing it here--
- [Audience Member] He actually though,
they did the documentary,
so he was running
so he actually did bounce back.
(audience talking)
- And by the way, we have to
contextualize bouncing back.
Is he gonna be the
governor of New York? No.
But where is he?
- But ruining lives, it's an
objective thing.
- Well that's where I'm going.
- I don't wanna get caught
up in what that means.
- Taylor Swift and the snakes
but also Taylor Swift and the
white supremacy happening--
- Yeah but let's talk about
it in a different way.
But Taylor Swift also used
that platform to create,
this has gotten very
philosophical, which by the way,
I'll live on, I love this shit,
but Taylor Swift is
going to have a hit song
in about 24 months.
- I'm interested to see
about the case though.
- Cool, we'll find out.
- Because I think she really
hit a peak, but she's, in my opinion,
I've got a lot of friends
who don't see her brand
as really reliable--
- Yeah, but a focus group
of seven is dangerous.
- I see you as being, like,
falling down on social media
as your child, that you are defending,
even if it is--
- Let me answer a better way.
I actually have zero
emotion for social media,
I don't give a fuck.
I'm being dead serious.
- I feel like 100% opposite
of what you're saying, you're
like defending it at all--
- I'm not I'm defending the
human race, I'm not defending,
I'm being serious!
I'm defending how humans
react and what we actually do
with each other, and
now that we have scale
to actually see it, it's
something that we're struggling
to completely quantify.
I mean it, I mean I'm
thrilled with the thought
of social media being
gone, I think we grossly,
I think we're starting to quantify
how unbelievably important
communications is,
and how it's dictated everything.
You know, I'm a child that
was born in the Soviet Union
where my mother's my hero, who tells me
at one point in my life
that she wrote a book report
that Fidel Casto was the
bravest man in the world,
and she read it to me,
and it just was like,
maybe because I had that Soviet
U.S. kind of thing goin' on,
I grew up in the '80s, I was
always hypersensitive to this,
the day after 9-11, I basically
spent three hours a day
on Al-Jazeera's website,
for two and a half years.
I'm fascinated by a man
walked in threw a grenade
and killed 27 kids in Washington state
and nobody in America knows about it.
This happened, like I'm
fascinated by communication.
And so I'm not defending social,
I just think that we should
have more complicated
conversations about it
and I think most people
take it very literal
and aren't looking at it,
I don't even wanna say it
that way, I don't think I'm
thinking about it better.
- I wanna ask you about--
- Can I ask you a question?
- Yes!
- Without social media,
the paparazzi would've put
up your picture.
- Yes.
I'm not saying that it's
awful, I'm on it Gary.
I think you're thinking that I'm saying
that it's the devil,
which I do think it is,
but I also think it's an
angel, I think it's both.
I think it's both.
- I think the question
where it all started
is does a piece of content ruin your life?
You know, at it's most basic.
I think it's more complicated than that.
I don't think it does.
- I think it's both.
I do think it's both, and unfortunately
I don't have the tools to debate you,
because if I had the
tools we would be going
so head to head, but my
silence is because I don't--
- Your silence is predicated on the fact
that you can spend all your time
between now and next year's class,
and your not gonna come up
with the example that isn't
attached to something egregious
in the actions.
- I'm not passionate enough
about this to really spend the time,
but if I was, you would go down.
It would be my jab jab right hook.
- Can somebody do the work for her?
- I find this stuff so fascinating.
I had Ted Koppel in my
reputation management class,
and he talked about the
democratization of content
and how everyone is a content creator
and I came back with, you know,
you have to be a
conscious content creator,
and I think what you're saying is,
anyone can put out content.
If the problem is, once
the content is out,
you have no control over it.
So it's not the content itself
that's causing the problem,
it's that once it's out of your hands,
it's up to interpretation.
And then the people who
are commenting on it,
it's out of your control.
So you might be putting it out there
in hopes of a certain reaction,
and maybe 50% will react the way you want.
The other 50% are gonna go haywire on you,
they're gonna take it
and they're gonna turn it
into something maybe
ugly or something that,
it's their sensibilities.
- My question is, what happens next?
Cool.
- What does that mean?
- What it means is, I think when,
back to the way the question was phrased
and I'm not picking on
it that way, it's like,
can a tweet, you know,
ruin someone's life?
I think the question
becomes, what happens next?
I think there's a second part,
you know when Richard reacted,
you hear it in the headline,
there's a moment in time, but
I'm just curious in the macro.
So sure, yeah like cool.
You said something that was misinterpreted
or interpreted properly, or
you said something wrong,
I mean like, it happens every day.
Like it happens 40,000 times a day.
Nipsy Hustle says something
that is inappropriate,
a day later it's not.
I mean I think we are
dramatically more forgiving,
back to my I'm debating for people,
the human race not social media,
I think we're massively
underestimating our ability
to still be sitting here
with all our capabilities
and I think there's a
gross under-estimation
of the human spirit and the
kindness and the empathy,
and I think that's what's playing out.
- I think, reverse is
sort of the life or death
or career ruining things,
what I find is often much more a effect
on the nature of what
you're able to discuss
as your business.
You know, I'm thinking about
these style bloggers I like,
and they're sort of getting
into reviewing Outlander,
which is a very passionate fan base,
and they said something like,
well, you now we're not
so into this plot line
or something like that,
and the fans just kind of leapt on them.
They basically decided, you know,
we're not gonna cover that show anymore
because it's not worth the effort for us,
and so they sort of pivoted
to other activities.
And I can think of lots of examples
like that where you might have to tailor
the activities of your
business, your brand,
your whatever to acknowledge
that inherent kind of swarm--
- But that's happened forever.
- Yeah, and I think it's
just different, it's sort of
what we're discussing.
- It's faster.
And it's shorter.
But I think the thing,
we're spending so much time
on the first 24 and 48 hours of the test,
and not talking about the actual impact,
and then more importantly,
what then that means to human behavior.
Once you go through a full cycle,
I think a lot of what you're seeing now,
emerging a decade into this,
is people being less fearful.
Everyone's like, oh
we're talking about less
and we're more scared.
I think we're more
courageous because people
are understanding that the ramifications
don't exist to the same level
and how that plays out
becomes interesting.
- So there's one thing, a
student, Benji, from last year.
You put a lot of pressure on him.
I remember him sitting in this room
and he said that that he's
trying to grow this base
of people and he maybe
wants to go into politics
and Africa, and he's a
television personality right now
and he's got all these people
and he kinda doesn't know
what to do with them.
And you said he needs to answer
as many of them as possible.
- Yes.
- And I saw his face,
and his face crumbled.
He just was like, what?
However, he took your advice
and he says that his
social media following
has grown threefold in one year,
and the embrace that he
gets from his country,
he feels has a lot to do
with what you told him to do,
which was engage.
Can you talk about that to this class,
and the importance of that.
- You know, not to re-harp
our last 15 minutes,
but I'm a very big fan
of doing the right thing
leads to the right thing,
and I think there's a lot of
different ways to look at it.
I'm blown away by the
selfishness of most people
as they try to build their personal brand.
It is 100% predicated on them, you know.
How many followers do they get,
how much is their engagement.
And so I remember that moment.
- It's just like, you were
like, try to answer all,
just put a heart, like,
just do as much as you can.
- If you have the luxury that
somebody finds you interesting
enough to consume what you have to say,
to not reciprocate that with an engagement
or an acknowledgement or listening
and more importantly for me,
I think one of the reasons
I've been able to map a
lot of this behavior is,
that's all I do.
My post is actually secondary,
it's what happens next and
my ability to interact,
and then that gives me insights.
You know, the insights you get
from actually reading
everyone of your replies
and then engaging with
them is extraordinary.
There is no data in the world
that's better than being a
human that's that in tune
with their audience
because you're picking up
on so many nuances.
Yeah, I couldn't believe in it more.
- Okay so let's take questions.
Anybody have questions?
- I have a question
about leading indicators.
You've talked about how you think voice
is gonna be the next big thing.
I agree with you and I think
that the leading indicator
there with that, we develop
the ability to analyze
that type of data, and that's the reason
that these devices are successful,
and so, how do you kind of
pick up leading indicators?
- So yours was a little
bit more quant based.
The technology is still pretty behind,
or advanced depending on
the filter you look through.
My leading indicator, you know,
is really just human behavior.
Like, I'll look at how many people,
just little subtle things start happening.
More anthropology and
qualitative stuff, like man,
a lot of people are really
listening to their headsets,
just like listening and the music
and then you start seeing podcasts
being talked about more often.
So, you know, maybe some
lightweight social listening,
but you're always trying to parallel
where the technology is.
The reason so many people lose money
that come from Stamford
is they're tech right,
they're human wrong.
- Can you talk about the podcast thing,
because I'm finding as I listen to them,
there's an addiction that I have to it
that's stronger than Netflix.
So I get in my car and I can't
reach for it fast enough.
What is that with voice?
- It could be a lot
of different things.
I'll tell you what
voice has, it's passive.
And so we can travel and do other things,
you're not required to watch.
And so, it fits where we've evolved into,
which is we wanna do multiple things,
and so we're on the go,
so the passive nature
of voice is remarkable.
Voice consumption of content,
which is why that will grow.
Obviously, the second part
and the more interesting part
of voice is the AI and the devices
and just making your life easier.
I mean, things like we
exchange information,
so I'll give you a great one.
You were in New York promoting your book.
I guarantee four years from now,
you would've been on my podcast,
because through voice, the
one time you would've thought
maybe I should reach out to Gary,
by the time you get to a phone,
you're onto another thought, you know.
- Because I was busy, but did a lot
of podcasts.
- No, I saw,
which was great.
No I mean, what I'm fascinated by
is everybody here is gonna book meetings
with each other through voice,
and it's gonna plug into the calendar app
and decide for us when we can meet.
There's so many efficiencies that voice
is gonna be able to do.
Passing thoughts is where I
was going with that analogy.
You know, to me leading indicators
are more human-based, right?
So I'll give you a good
example: online dating.
To me, the leading
indicator was watching who
and when they started using online dating,
not that the technology existed
to connect people together.
Stigma, Uber.
You know, you can't tell
a parent 15 years ago
that there gonna want
their 14-year-old daughter
to take rides with strange men at night,
'cause that's gonna be
safer than them driving.
So, there's stigmas that
we have to get over.
Robots. That one's gonna be the big one.
- Like I said, me with the
Alexa, and I'm like ugh.
Like it's not gonna be
like that for my son.
- [Audience Member] So in a little bit
of a more practical sense,
so how much planning should
you do before you post
or if you're working a podcast,
how much do you write it out
before you do it?
- Zero for me.
Probably a lot more for you
since you're asking it that way.
I think again, I'm telling
you, self-awareness, right?
And lack of judging yourself.
There is absolute, it's
cliche, no right way.
It depends on, you know, if
you're an improv actor none,
if you need to read the
script 30 times, you know,
and so like it's a very personal mission,
and to try achieve to somebody else,
it's just like a hockey player
wanting to become a
basketball player, like why?
You're a great hockey player.
- So you talked about self-awareness
and being in touch with audiences.
How do you deal with
people who are trolls?
They farm these people,
people who are impersonating other people.
- Empathy, empathy.
For me, how do I? Empathy.
Like I get a ton of hate, I'm empathetic.
If you are taking the
time to spew negativity
on me out of your day, you're
coming from a bad place.
And so to me, it's empathy.
Like I'm so grateful that
that would not be a gear,
and so, I don't think, I'm not worried
about the judgment of others, you know.
And everybody has different
levels of securities
and insecurities and everybody's got
their trigger points and I have mine too.
But for me, it's a cost of entry.
And to be frank, for me
it's far more empathy,
and then for others in
here, I would just tell you,
to let an anonymous social media comment
take you away from your ambitions
is really not a good idea.
- I'd say, we are human
beings and it hurts,
but would I try to do as fast as possible
is like it hurts and
then push it back out,
and to get it away from
me as much as I can.
And sometimes it's just
going past that person,
sometimes it's muting them.
It depends on how nasty the hate is,
sometimes it's blocking
them and then I get nervous,
I'm like wait I blocked them
and now they're gonna see
that I blocked them and then
they're a super hateful person
so it's just gonna make
them even more hateful
and show up outside.
So, you know, there's just
all of these kind of levels
and you have to kind of
pause, especially as a female,
you have to pause and go, is this a block,
is this an ignore, or is this a mute.
Jason?
- So I created a show that I
pushed out through Facebook
and it's video, how do
you see video consumption
on Facebook versus YouTube,
proceeding into the future.
- Well I think you should do both,
because there's no reason not to.
I'm not sure, but they'll both be there.
- Different content or same, duplicates?
- I'm fine with same.
Obviously I do think that
they're slightly different enough
where you can do some
contextually different things,
but, for example, actions
better than words.
My daily vlog goes on
both pretty much the same.
The copy's a little different,
I community manage a little different,
but I think they're both
gonna be massive players.
Like, massive players.
- So you mention that
nine out of ten operators
ignore when you don't have it.
What is that it?
- If I deepen that statement,
there's the entertainment
value that they think
they need to go into, similar to how much
should you prep or not,
is what I mean by it.
Being entertaining on
video is a real skill.
And so, just a lot of people that are,
especially if you're a CFO,
you know, math-driven operator,
you know there's people that have both,
but you can already see that
so many of them don't map.
You know there's the
left, the right thing.
So that, I struggle with,
I get sad for my friend
who's building a great sass business
and she thinks that she needs
to start a YouTube show,
and I'm like, you don't have to,
you're building an incredible business.
You can, I'm thrilled to help you,
but, and you definitely don't have
to be like super charismatic and like,
360 drone videos.
It gets away from people.
- There's also beauty in an NPR voice.
You guys hear that voice?
It's just a thing, and
it is not razzle-dazzle,
it's kinda monotone, and
it just the most soothing
thing in the world.
And so that's now a thing.
- Betting on strengths.
- That voice was not,
what, telegenic or autogenic,
or whatever you wanna call it
type of voice, and now it is.
- So, I'm curious what
you think about the role
of social media in grant
building for businesses
that are not individuals.
Because I can seek out the first way
when brands would put up
their content in general
and then use social media
just to amplify the content.
So the second way, when you have companies
like Tribal that gets to a
hundred million of revenues,
swimsuits on like eight employees,
and other social media being
farmed out to the Philippines.
And so I'm curious, where do you see
the brand building--
- I think that 80%
of the money that Fortune 500s spend
should be on social media websites.
I think Facebook is the grossly,
most under priced stock of all time.
- And using it how?
What do you think for a
company that, you know,
Fortune 500 established companies--
- The same thing they did on print,
radio, television, outdoor.
Pictures and videos, right?
You know, Kyle Jenner's cosmetic
company did $487,000,000
in sales in the last 12 months.
And people think it's
her social, it's not.
It's the content their making on Facebook
and Instagram and running ads against.
My friends, Facebook ads
are so grossly under priced,
and right now they're running
between six and eight,
ten dollar CPMs, they're
gonna be 50, 70, 80,
there's only one stream.
It's supply and demand.
As soon as BMW and Coca Cola
figure this out and their money comes in,
it's gonna be hard for our startups
to penetrate that feed.
This is the time.
And it's been the time.
- More a personal question.
So, I love the idea that
social media exposes us
it doesn't change us, and I'm curious
how you thought about a level of exposure,
because that's ultimately
the choice that we have
is how much we're exposing over time.
And what decisions you've
made and how that's changed.
- So, similar to Tyra,
and I've been putting
out content since 2006,
there's literally not a
single photo of my family
on the internet.
You know, that's something
my wife and I decided,
we didn't wanna put, because
as my notoriety grew,
we knew that there would
be ramifications to that--
- People ask for it,
don't they constantly?
I wanna see your kids--
- Well it's really funny, I mean, so many,
like that's the move by
most business people.
They use their kids and their animals to,
because they actually think the currency
is how many likes they get.
And this is the thing, it's always to me,
like what are you doing?
Like, cool, you got 10,000 likes,
but did you sell anymore swimsuits?
What are you trying to accomplish?
So Sarah, I feel very in control,
and I also recognize that people
can film and everything in that nature.
To me, what's in control
and why I love this so much
and why I'm unbelievably
optimistic about this,
I really am, is you're in
control of your actions.
- So your family, I'm just curious,
is there talk of anything
else that you've done.
Like I was really thinking
about being more deliberate
about this going forward,
how you made that decision
about what is exposed and what isn't.
- I go the other way, and
Iris will tell you this
and the rest of my team.
I'm completely fully on the
record because I just am,
like I'm just not worried
about the collateral damage
'cause I know what my intent is.
If I make a mistake, that's
life and I should own up to it.
I don't think they're gonna
be the kind of mistakes
that we've referred to
earlier, things of that nature.
I'm probably the most extreme.
I've gone to a place where I'm filming
every single moment of my life.
- Have you filmed on the toilet?
- I have.
I had a vine that went super viral
four years ago on the toilet.
And obviously that's for fun
and you're kinda being
a little silly about it,
but I mean, you know this gets,
again I already went heady
enough I can get real heady.
What I would say is
this: you're in control.
- What are you thinking
Sarah, specifically.
- One thought that I had
when you were saying that
is how some of the power that you have
is how much you're putting out.
And so there's some dilution effect
that comes from that as well.
- But that's the beauty
of the meritocracy of it.
It's not how much you put out,
it's the value exchange
that you're creating.
So it's not how much you're putting out,
because to your point, you can dilute
if you're unable to maintain.
If you're able to be, if
you have value to bring,
whether through
entertainment or information,
it only exponentially
allows you to produce more.
- You're saying in terms of
yourself, like diluting yourself
by posting too much, posting
too personal, posting--
- Yeah, so if you overexpose.
(unclear response)
- And I think overexposure was something
that was dramatically more relevant
when you had platforms
that had so much awareness.
A hit T.V. show in 1983 had
50% of the country watching it.
There's nothing that has
that much attention anymore,
so it's almost impossible to overexpose.
We are not calibrating
the true long tail effect
of the internet and its
impact on communication
and all the sub-impacts
that are created from that.
- Alright, we're gonna wrap up.
- You've seen my content, it sounds like
you do more creating content,
I was wondering how do
you think about that
on a day to day basis
and how does that affect
your relationships with
people in real time.
Like, you just spend so
much time on your phone
that you feel like it
affects your relationships.
- Well first of all, I think it's micro
because the macro is that
I work 18 hours a day,
that affects my relationship
a hell of a lot more.
At home, or when I'm with
friends, I don't consume anything.
I'm with them, the problem
is, that's only 20%
of my time overall.
- Got it.
- So for example, on the weekend,
like when I'm really home,
I consume very little.
And I create even less.
- So it's really more
the consumption, the
creation of what throws back
to your job and outside of that--
- Correct, correct.
I kinda made a quick reference to it,
which is like, I almost
debate if I would be on it
but I genuinely am curious
if I would've used it
had this not been my life.
You know what's weird about that?
I also don't think I
would've drank alcohol
if I didn't grow up in the wine business.
Like I didn't have a
single beer, you know,
so it's been funny that my
life is kind of like that.
But because it is my business.
And again, I kinda broke it down,
my business is people's attention.
Like I don't consume anything,
I don't watch YouTube videos,
I don't, I just, I will watch
a tweet in its individuality,
not she posted it.
Her posting about a
subject matter and you guys
engaging with it is what I'm consuming.
Which is why, I'm sure you even can tell,
it's not about being right or wrong
and I think my points of view are grounded
in an obnoxious amount
of practitioner-ship,
and an awful lot of energy towards
trying to figure it out for an
awfully long period of time.
- Got it, that's helpful.
- But to me, I'll tell you something else.
Let me actually answer your
question now in a different way.
I think it's great that
every single person
sitting at a dinner table
looking at their phones,
it means that they don't value
that person in that moment.
So I'll give you an example.
If you're always with
your best fuckin' friend,
like always, would you spend, in college,
you're always together, at work.
If you go to a restaurant
and you're both on the phone
and he comes in and sees that
and he's judging technology,
you're missing so much of the context
of why that's happened.
If you're a married couple
and you're on your phones
the whole time on your one
dinner date every Thursday night,
that's probably a leading indicator
that you're marriage
is not in a good place.
So I, again, it's not
that I love social media,
it's that I love people.
Of course, people will give you the tell.
I understand so much about everybody here
just on how they dress.
That is your biggest
indicator to, I think we,
I like to deeply think about
the psychology of it all.
So to me, people judging
somebody being on a phone
is just a very shallow point of view.
What's underneath that is everything.
- I'm really excited
to be on social media.
I don't know, like for
me, it's like Facebook,
I didn't just wanna have
the profiles and have that,
but I don't really post content on it.
- I get it man, I unbelievably don't think
it's a requirement, I think
it's leaving something
on the table for a business
opportunity for sure,
but okay, what's more
interesting to me about that.
What do you want, right?
Like if you want a practice
that does three million a year,
you can get to that easily without social
and then if that's what you wanted,
then that's what you have.
- Well I think there's like the difference
between the business
and the personal side,
the business side just isn't relevant yet.
- Well what do you do?
Or what do you wanna be?
- So I'm going into finance
doing investigative advisory.
- Great, so what I know is you writing
one Linkedin blog post about your thought
of blockchain's impact on the yen
could be the single piece of content
that changes the course of your career.
I think content is the
gateway drug to opportunity,
but I don't think anything
is required for you to do.
- Thank you.
- Pleasure.
How are you?
- Good to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
- So I'm big into this,
I'm sort of like Benji I'm a public figure
back in my home country
Kenya, I was an olympian,
carried the Olympic flag
in the opening ceremony.
- So a lot of awareness in Kenya
and surrounding countries, maybe?
- Yeah and the region and growing,
and I've only really
been focused on Facebook,
more recently in the last
year when I started realizing
how the brand won't cache,
I hadn't really been doing nothing
and had a little bit of
an organic following.
So then I started the show,
which also, it's like me
sitting down with people
and interviewing, so I think
it's suited for podcast
but haven't gotten around
that, but Facebook--
- But here's the great thing.
So for example right now,
this is a podcast as well.
What's amazing about video
is you could strip the audio.
Like I'm a top 100 podcast in the world,
and I never sit down and do a podcast.
It's just ripped audio, like
I'm sure it's probably gonna
be the, I'm sure that
rant with me and Tyra
is gonna be an episode
in seven to 15 days.
- Okay, fantastic--
- So you should rip the audio
and now you've got a podcast.
And that's important,
don't create friction
for your audience.
- Perfect.
- Some people wanna listen,
you know what I mean?
- And do it at your own pace,
is that a good place, or--
- No, I think if you're
filming, you're doing the show
where you're filming--
- Yeah I've done
over one hundred
interviews since last year.
- You've got a hundred podcasts there,
just rip the audio and upload it.
You don't even need to use
anchor, you can upload it.
- Okay yeah, just find that time.
And then in terms of
Twitter, I love being engaged
with others. So I mean, should I--
- That's huge.
- Okay great.
- It's the easiest gateway into the game.
You need a designer, you
don't need a video person.
Just engage.
- An Instagram strategy
is photos of me with people, or--
- Sure, try it all, you see that look--
- There's no rules,
like don't constrain yourself.
- There's no rules.
There's you, the biggest rule is you.
Like for example, I don't put myself
with photos of famous people.
I don't like it, I don't know why.
I would never ask Tyra for
a selfie, I don't like it.
But other people, but that
doesn't mean I'm right or wrong.
It's being right or wrong for yourself,
but it's content.
You gotta put out content.
And people overthink it and overthink it
and then you're just not producing.
- That's fantastic.
I'm actually trying to get
into broadcast journalism
like more traditionally
and be a news anchor.
- It's gonna be the
leverage, because this world
is bigger than traditional,
so it's going like this.
So you gotta do it and
it will get you there,
or it will just become it.
You'll realize that you'll be able
to keep all the economics.
- Great, thank you so much.
- Good luck.
- I have a question more
roughly and then just a question
about stuff like Christian.
So when I post an image,
it's an emotional
connection to that image.
- For you.
- For me.
- Okay.
- And, even for other people
when they interact with a it.
When I say something, I'm like
oh, my voice, it's horrible.
And I don't have the same
emotional connection--
- Good.
- So what,
I guess, does that experience resonate,
is that just in my head,
is that a reason that podcast may not be--
- Correct!
- The go to?
- That's right, that's right.
I mean, this is, so I knew blogging
was gonna be big in 2003
2004, but I didn't do it.
'Cause I was running a wine business,
I didn't have the luxury of
being able to afford a writer,
and I can't write.
It's just not my thing, so I had to watch
that whole train go by.
Yeah, that's what I think is so special
about a mature internet, now
they're all in play, right?
Whether you wanna do a podcast or audio,
whether you wanna do video,
whether you wanna write.
They all have massive
scale, so I feel like,
you could be a cartoonist!
You could be an animator, like,
our ability to communicate,
yeah I think that's, I view that as
what everybody's going through.
- And then this is another
question that's more specific
to my passion project
is I have an Instagram
dedicated to baths, like
aesthetically pleasing baths.
- I get it.
And bath bombs?
- Bath bombs is the network
though, you're right.
- Oh it's huge.
- It's the groove that
I'm kinda engaged with.
And I'm doing it more to
see if I can grow something,
and I struggle with growing.
I've chosen a vertical,
my images are consistent,
how--
- How many, well because,
because that's just one tenth of it all.
A growth strategy around
distribution matters.
Like, what hashtags do
you use, who do you DM,
how you collaborate,
is it totally organic,
there's so many variables.
- What do you think,
follow for follow, not cool.
Okay. (laughs)
- Because all your pandering
to is one vanity metric
that isn't the indicator to the reality.
It's a kind of a philosophical
question we had there.
We're just having too
much surface level convos.
Surface level, no strategy,
surface level, right?
I would tell you that the people
that are growth hacking and
getting 500,000 followers
the wrong way, trick the masses,
but lose with the real
currency, and then lose.
- Yeah, that's true.
That's all I had, thank you.
- The real version of follow for follow
is spending 40 minutes while
you're laying on your bed
'cause you're passionate about it,
hitting hashtags and that culture,
and going in, reading and watching
or looking at the photo, and
then meaningfully writing
two sentences to add to the conversation
on the photo that you just saw.
Got it?
It's a, everything you're hearin' from me
is like, do the right
thing, good things happen,
do the wrong thing, wrong things happen.
It's actually that black and white.
- So I wanna talk about
starting a following
and I think you kinda
went into a little bit.
So one of the things that
I'm really interested in
is I'm moving to New York
and I'm gonna be an investment banka,
and it's a space where you
don't see a lot of black women,
you don't see a lot of plus size women
in professional services--
- This is like a huge home run for you.
- Yeah, that's kinda the group
I wanna target here.
- 100%.
- And I'm debating, do I try to like,
start my own hashtag and following,
or do I try--
- Nobody owns a hashtag.
There's no such thing.
Because by nature, it can be hijacked
once it becomes something.
There's nobody that owns it.
So don't even think about that ever again.
Because, think about it,
whatever clever financial,
plus size, African-American people,
whatever you come up
with, if god would forbid,
AKA I hope it gets going, well
then everyone's gonna use it,
it's not an own-able, it's
a utility for discovery,
it's not an own-able thing.
- So you would say like, for example,
there's a hashtag I love,
eff your beauty standards,
and a lot of plus size women follow it--
- I'm aware of it, I know about it.
- And so I wonder, should
I start putting content
out there and using that
hashtag, that vogue--
- That to me is a hell of a lot better.
As long as you're not doing it where,
you have to be thoughtful right, because,
for example, if you go hashtag right now
Gary B wine club, which is my wine club,
there's like six spammers
sorta just putting
their propaganda over it, so all my fans
who are watching my wine
videos tryin' to find
other people to talk about wine
are getting inundated with shit.
If you jump into and write a hashtag,
you probably wanna be
respectful of the hashtag.
So I'm assuming since you're
a part of that culture, fine,
but if then if all your content
is very hardcore finance,
it kinda defeats it, so you have
to be clever and respectful.
Does that make sense?
- Yeah, that makes
a lot of sense.
And then, my second question was,
so when you're starting
to think about this,
the way I think of it is,
probably start with Instagram,
like get my face out
there, like my outfits,
all of that--
- I, well it depends,
let me ask you a question.
Are you trying to take note to,
that you're an investment banker
that doesn't look the part,
or are you just tryin' to build
overall personal brand equity?
- I'm trying to take that
I'm an investment banker
that doesn't look the part
and inspire other women in
other professional services.
- So I would tell you, I would tell you
that you really have to get serious
about Instagram and get
serious about writing
or making videos on Instagram.
Because, you're going to make a quicker,
more meaningful impact on
that platform and my belief,
because you're gonna start with people
that are living the game
versus aspiring to the game,
Instagram and the psychology
and what's going on there,
I think you're gonna
find a lot of friction.
Now I would say do both,
but I would highly recommend
you to give a lot of thought to LinkedIn
and to whether you write
or you audio or you video, communicate.
- That's good, so I had Instagram
and then writing blog
posts and posting them
into my Linkedin.
- Yeah to me, use LinkedIn
and Facebook as your blog,
because it has built in distribution,
whereas your own blog at first, I think,
whereas that was right in the early 2000s,
I think building a blog
comes secondary now
because you can siphon the distribution
and awareness from these platforms.
And what's really crazy,
and I don't think people realize this,
these platforms are
rewarding long writing.
I would tell you one of the weirdest hacks
that I stumbled on by accident,
hence why I always do so much 'cause this
is how you find it, there's
a Wilmington post I wrote,
I just was in the mood
and I just wrote, right.
And it did well, I'm
like okay, interesting.
I think Instagram is one of
the most interesting places
to start a blog, where the
photo is 50% of the equation.
It's the write, there's just so much,
it's why I start with attention.
Where there's attention
there's opportunity,
and what something starts as evolves.
Television does not look
like the television shows
it started as.
There's evolution.
- Great, thank you.
- Cool, you're welcome,
good luck.
- Can I pick up
on her question, I'm Jessica.
- Nice to meet you.
- When you're thinking about,
you have different messages
and different things you talk about.
Like I like retail, I'm a spin instructor,
I wanna write short stories
and all these different things.
How do I push into the different channels
and do I have to dedicate one
channel to a specific thing.
- I love where you're goin' with this,
it's a really thoughtful question.
Couple things, number one.
Everyone of you are
fundamentally different
when you're in a different
social network, psychologically.
You are fundamentally different.
When you are literally
on your phone in Linkedin
versus when you're on Instagram,
you're just so different
you can't even imagine.
Just like you'd be different in class
than going to Vegas with
your girls for the weekend.
We've got multiple gears.
So yes, I think distribution,
and that's what I alluded to very quickly,
distribution and content
are so much more married
than they've ever been,
so yes I'm very thoughtful
about what I put in
Linkedin versus what I put,
I mean my delta between,
especially because who I am,
and I play that way,
the delta between what,
I mean I'm putting things on Snapchat
about like Lil Xan, which I'm
not gonna put on Linkedin.
So I'm playing very high low.
And to that point as well.
On the flip side, I actually
think a lot of times
the white space is being
a little bit bubbly
or funny or lighthearted on Linkedin.
I think breaking the
normal patterns also works.
So my answer to your question is,
all the cliched shit that
we're thinking right now,
do that 80% of the time, right?
My business stuff on Linkedin.
But I do think 20% of the
content, to throw it off,
also works because you're
breaking up patterns.
- Just within that question,
I think you might've asked this,
within a platform,
so like an Instagram for example,
I have a brand and I'm a
singer and I have my personal.
Like, do you recommend
different profiles--
- No, no.
And I think, this is
the point I was making
and we obviously went into
the outer space with it,
I don't think a single piece of content
is as heavy as everybody else does.
I don't think if you're
branded as a singer
on your Instagram that if you made a post
about your little sister
or liking cheeseburgers
or what you thought about
yesterday's tornado,
that some like catastrophic event
of you breaking the theme.
And there's so much ego,
there's a lack of humility
and empathy from us in the way
we're deploying this content,
we're in our own shit.
You know, one post doesn't mean shit.
And once you realize that,
then it gets real easy.
- I don't know if you
talked about this already,
but what is the role of like,
what used to be blogging is
sort of now long form radicals,
I know you can post
professional things on Linkedin,
but I see a lot of people using Medium
or other places to get kind
of like, thought pieces or,
for me I come from performing arts.
I wanna like showcase like,
what is my inspiration,
what am I thinking about?
- I just referenced to your point,
I think there's a lot
of places you can write.
So as long as you're really
invested in your medium,
I think Ed Williams is
actually the best entrepreneur
of this generation, building tools.
I love Medium, I like Linkedin,
but I'll tell you I think
Facebook and Instagram
are unbelievable platforms for long form.
I will tell you this.
No question, a great piece
of long form written word
has more potential to
catch fire on Facebook
than anywhere else.
- And so, that's obviously,
like using Facebook
as a pass through, send it, posting it,
even if I have like a personal website--
- I wouldn't, I wouldn't.
I would write it natively on Facebook.
- In the post.
- Uh huh.
Because my belief is that the attention
is worth more than utility
of owning that traffic.
For me it's build brand.
You know, people are always
thinking transactional.
Let me have it on my
website so they come there
and then they may use me.
To me the brand equity
is so much more valuable.
You writing natively in
Facebook versus it being
a link out to your blog has
a distribution capability
of a thousand delta
because it's not native
and Facebook's gonna downgrade that.
You've gotta, again, that
was a very detailed example
of respecting the distribution.
You have to know how
the distribution works.
And I'll give it to you
basic as you go through it.
Always make it about the audience.
The audience doesn't wanna click
your fucking link to go to your website,
they just wanna read
it in fucking Facebook.
- But what if your audience isn't there?
- Then if your audience isn't there,
then you shouldn't do anything, right?
I'm with you, you don't
have to everything.
Now, I referenced it earlier
with the Snapchat thing,
if your audience is not there,
and that's what you want
your audience to be,
the answer's that you
don't need to be there.
There's two more thoughtful points though.
Number one, is there an audience there
that can bring awareness to the audience
you're trying to reach
and that's why Facebook
is so powerful, right?
The amount of times
I've been able to reach
millennials by writing
articles to 60-year-olds
and having them print it out
and give it to their child,
like shit like that.
And then number two, be
careful because sometimes
your audience eventually gets there.
So like, when I was tryin' to get brands
to build Facebook up in 2007 and 2008,
they were like, this is my company,
our customers are not there.
I'm like, yet.
And the reason I'm really,
one of my big breakthroughs
early on the internet
was I coined something
called the grandmother rule.
I saw early Facebook
people that were graduating
from college start to have children
or maybe they had children early,
and they were posting photos
and I was like, this is it.
I remember it like yesterday,
I was like if they're gonna
be posting their photos here,
their fuckin' mother's gonna
be on this in two minutes.
And that's exactly what happened.
And so, Dab and Campbell's
like, our customer's not there,
it was only 36 months
later that they were.
And then they were behind.
Got it?
- My objective is
building for the building
with my intended audience
which is entrepreneurs,
hospitality, customer, and retail.
Then my Facebook is, my
friends and people that I know,
it's not--
- That's your Facebook
personal page, you mean?
- Yeah.
- Create a business page
and start making content
for that audience, got it?
- Do you put your name?
- Your name, your name.
Like if you go and search
me on Facebook right now,
you'll see, actually I think
that might be my default
photo for one of them.
There's my, the one I
had from the beginning,
like what have you, and
then there's the one
that I actually use.
- So yeah, I'm the one guy
without an Instagram account.
- Two, the guy behind you too, Adam.
You guys are both fighting the system.
- Well, I just actually created one, so.
Thank you. (laughs)
So the question I had was,
separating out personal from business,
because I'm not trying to
build a personal brand.
But--
- You're trying to establish
a reputation, here's, here's
where I was about to go.
Guys, this is reputation.
Because the word personal,
a lot of times we get caught
up in semantics of words.
Because this is personal
brand, it fucks with us.
What we're really talking
about is reputation.
So, all of us would want
that for some reason.
So again, like I told
Adam when he was like meh,
I was like yeah but you're one piece
on the blockchains of impact on the yen
may be great for your business.
It's just putting out the content.
What I'll tell you is,
and this is where a lot
of people get caught,
Facebook's virality and scale is so great,
I would argue often, it's going to over
index your business nerdy business content
than what you would do on Linkedin.
Because you have to
understand, let's go cliche.
The old white dude who fuckin' golfs
and runs the fuckin' business
that you're tryin' to reach.
He's on Facebook.
Like people don't get it.
Especially now, now that politics
is playing out on Facebook,
the establishment is living on Facebook.
And so, sure, he or she
may be on her Facebook
looking at their college friends
that graduated in '68,
but if your piece of
content shows up there
and they read it, your point of view
on viable chemical engineer, like.
People don't get it, it's scale.
- I have a question on content.
So, a quick backstory,
I was in public service,
California, Sonoran Business School,
and tryin' to do something like start ups,
relationships, social mission driven
and helping entrepreneurs
of color and women,
so my initial thought was tryin'
to start a podcast this summer
with people who are
kinda like cross sector,
because I'm tryin' to
figure out how do I create
some type of reputation
like being business person
because it's really
hard to shake government
when you work in that for so,
I was in it for five years,
right, but it does brand you--
- Oh yeah, I'm like your terrible.
You know the idea.
I'm kidding but yes, I think that's right.
So I think you could have two guests.
One from each sector and crush.
I love the two guest podcast format
because then you're able to siphon equity
from both angles.
Now you have to be good enough,
like it takes skill to be a host
that can manage two people at once.
But by the way, maybe you're great at it,
but I think people take a
lot of things for granted.
- So my other question was
how to respond to less content,
I'm trying to think of other
ways for people to consume
if you like still. (background noise)
- I would film your podcast
and then chop up pieces of highlights
and distribute throughout different places
based on what happened.
Let me make a point that I
think all of you are gonna get.
And this will really tie a
lot of this into a nice bow.
You have to think of
yourself as a media company
not as an advertiser.
If you actually say, wait a minute,
I'm actually CNN or
the Wall Street Journal
or ESPN or Vogue, not I wanna
be an advertiser in Vogue,
it changes the way you think about things.
I only think about bringing
value to the audience,
not extracting value from the audience.
Advertising extracted value,
the content was giving value,
that was the exchange of media.
We as humans and businesses
need to use these distribution platforms
to be the content, not the advertiser.
And that's where people get tripped up.
'Cause you're thinkin' about
it from the filter of like,
what's in it for me, like I'm gonna,
I want to write a book
about this or move up,
get promoted, whatever it may be.
Or, you know, make an impact,
like have the leverage,
raise capital off of my equity, whatever.
Your only thinking about
what's in it for you.
For me, I'm only thinkin'
about what's in it for you,
because I know the collective
scale of attention has,
the collateral damage
of that much attention
is unlimited opportunity for me.
- So Tyra talked about
beginning to share that article
about how--
- The Third Party.
- Talking about
self-promotion in the context
of serving your audience.
- So self-promotion is
eye of the beholder.
Is it self-promoting that,
I would view her posting it herself
and saying she's teaching at Stamford,
I think what she was doing
was extracting equity.
She was extracting equity
from Wall Street Journal
because she comes from
a modeling background
and so business elevates,
she's transitioning
and wants to be more
respected, that equity matters.
- Why does it matter for her audience?
- Because it changes the
dynamics of how she's seen.
It changes the conversation.
It's in her best interest,
she's not, notice how
she's not using Vogue
or People Magazine because
she's already won that game.
She hasn't won this
game, thus she uses it.
It's value exchange.
It's not self-promotion,
that wasn't self-promoting.
No I'm not being critical
either, I'm just high energy.
Think about how she, she
positioned it that way
but that's not what it was.
Not in my point of view.
- Readers of the Wall Street Journal
got something out of it--
- Not the readers of the Wall
Street Journal, my friend.
No, her, she got something
out of it with her audience.
She was able to change the perception
to her audience on
Instagram that follows her
for being a model, got it?
That was a value exchange for her, right?
It's why you see a lot
of high low happening
in culture now.
21 Savage having a meeting with Jeff Bezos
is a value exchange for both.
Why is Robert fuckin' Kraft
hanging out with Meek Mill?
It's a value exchange.
For Meek Mill, he goes
in the hood and culture
and gets to say I'm mogul life,
Robert Kraft gets to say that he's on,
he gets it, he's got flavor.
He's contemporary, he's young.
Value exchange, that's
what's happening here.
And that's why, taking it a step back,
the reason I'm so over-indexed
is because my value exchange
is I figured out a way
to bring so much value to people
without asking for anything in return
because I'm monetizing in other areas,
not tryin' to get you guys
into my $3,000 a month master class.
It's why, this is gonna be
one of the only five colleges
left pretty soon.
- So is it self-promotion if
it's within your own industry?
- You're so you, personally,
off of two conversations,
have to think about, no no, it's amazing.
This is why I'm here.
You have to have a totally
different conversation
with yourself, which is you are valuing
other people's opinions too much.
You know.
(laughs)
And this goes back to, both of you,
you talked about dynamics
of women versus men
in self-promotion, you brought up
obviously being an African-American woman,
listen to me.
This is the most exciting,
most passion-able thing.
Oh, great, I brought it up.
My mother is my hero, right?
Like I went to a 94%
African-American college
of low income, just went out of business,
like I've lived a life that put me
far more into places that
weren't, like I look like.
I grew up in Edison, New Jersey,
where all my best friends
were Indian immigrants.
Like I've lived a very great
life to give me a perspective.
This internet thing is the fucking game.
It doesn't care.
You have to understand
how powerful this is.
Watching all my most
progressive liberal friends,
which I'm an absolute
social liberal person,
being mad at technology,
but it is the unlock
to the thing that they've always wanted.
I'm like, my friends, we've had it one way
for 90 years, and you're not
happy with the way it is.
Don't you understand this is the thing?
So, you're so caught up
on this self-promotion
because of the judgment
and thinking there's,
people think in fancy, respectful,
finance, Wall Street,
fancy fuckin' places,
that self-promotion's a negative.
It's just not.
Let's start with that,
and what people are doing
in that world is their disguising it.
Let me tell you what's disgusting.
- This is a get with the program.
- And here's the best part, right?
I'm gonna be right not because I'm smart,
because I'm living so deep in the vortex
and just watching, it's already happened.
This has already happened.
This has happened.
This is not like it's coming.
If you look at every single
thing that's happening.
You think the fuckin' four old white guys
that owned all of media in America
were gonna let Me Too happen 20 years ago?
What do you think's happening?
I invest in a lot of female companies,
like six, seven years ago,
on the back of knowing
they weren't getting funded properly.
It was like a business
thing, it's not like
'cause I'm the most noble man.
It was just like stupid, for me it's like,
I don't care who you
are, this is business.
That's the last thing you
should be thinking about.
Like, so a lot of my
girl friends are like,
Gary but cool, fuck man,
but they're like guess what, cool Gary
but I still can't get funding
from fucking VCs, so I'm
like don't take money
from VCs, they're bad deals anyway.
My friends, this whole fuckin' thing
we're in right now, it's had a great run,
and it's really cool, and
I'm super happy for it,
but it's in deep shit.
It's in deep fuckin' shit.